the pentagon says there were no u.s
casualties following a
rocket attack on an iraqi base housing
u.s and other troops
officials say at least three rockets
landed on the al-assad air base in
western iraq
damage is being assessed there has been
no claim of responsibility the u.s has
accused iran-backed militia groups
of launching similar attacks in recent
weeks
the pentagon says the us withdrawal from
afghanistan will be complete by late
late next month but the administration
is being criticized for what many
experts predict
will happen when the troops are gone
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin takes a look tonight
the top u.s general in afghanistan who
left the country friday described in an
exit interview what he observed as u.s
and nato forces withdrew
if you look at the security situation
it's not good
the taliban now control the northern
passage and border crossing to
tajikistan
where the u.s just spent 40 million
dollars to create a customs crossing
point for the afghan government
now the taliban have a source of revenue
to fuel their insurgency
the loss of terrain and the rapidity of
that loss of terrain
has to be concerning one because hope
actually matters and morale actually
matters
and so as you watch the taliban moving
across the country
what you don't want to have happen is
that the people lose hope
people who have enough money leave
afghanistan every day we see thousands
of people lining up behind the gates of
the passport department in various
embassies
so that they can leave afghanistan
sooner the pentagon is now negotiating
with uzbekistan north of afghanistan to
serve as a drone base in the region
now that the u.s does not have the use
of bagram airfield north of kabul
we just handed bagram air base over to
the afghans
which is a strategic asset in the region
to protect us from terrorists it
counters russia china
and iran in the region we're going dark
in afghanistan
and there can be consequences long-term
to this in terms of the thousands of
afghan translators and their families
that the u.s promised visas
who have been facing death threats from
the taliban for their past
work with the u.s government congressman
mccall says the u.s
is negotiating with kazakhstan to serve
as a base for them
to wait while the u.s processes those
visa requests
mike jennifer griffin at the pentagon
thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else